[Música]
con él vamos a analizar lo que busca
Rusia con los referendos realizados en
los territorios ocupados en Ucrania
además de la situación con las fugas de
los gasoductos nord Stream en el mar
Báltico para ellos solo Vamos a Nicolás
de Pedro él es analista senior del
institute for statecraft esto en Londres
Gracias Nicolás a buena mañana de
miércoles Gracias por estar con nosotros
en directo América de Francia 24 que
busca Rusia con estos referendos ejerzo
en saprilla Luján y Daniels digamos esto
remonta a los recuerdos de 2014 con
crimea quiere entonces de Putin
anexionarse estos territorios a toda
costa
bueno Esto es el escenario más probable
hay programado anunciado para mañana un
discurso del presidente Putin a la
relación rusa y una vez que se han hecho
público los resultados y son todos en
firman por el del Rango del 96 al 99% en
estos cuatro provincias ucranianas Pues
lo más previsible es que que anuncie no
que acepta o que instala duma a que
acepte la anexión de estos territorios a
la federación rusa eso supondrá un
cambio significativo del marco del
conflicto desde la perspectiva rusa en
la medida que ahora rusa crea Rusia
Perdón creará la ficción de que está
defendiendo O sea que Ucrania está
atacando territorio nacional Ruso y eso
le confiere a Rusia la legitimidad y el
derecho a utilizar cualquier recurso a
su alcance no que es una digamos una un
eufemismo para o la idea de para
transmitir de forma velada la
posibilidad de utilizar armamento
nuclear
realmente estaría dispuesto Pues en
Rusia el creming a usar este armamento
nuclear no teniendo en cuenta
evidentemente pues todas las
consecuencias de lo que es un conflicto
en nuclear no y digamos que estamos
hablando de que esto representaría un
punto de inflexión en la guerra Cómo se
podría desarrollar este conflicto armado
de aquí en adelante cuando ya Putin
digamos que reconozca de alguna manera
estos territorios como suyos
bueno la respuesta si puede utilizar
armamento nuclear la respuesta corta es
que sí aunque yo creo que en este
momento lo que el kremlin está
intentando es
hacer una escalada retórica diplomática
para
intimidar sobre todo a los europeos con
vistas a que fuercen a Ucrania a aceptar
una negociación en los términos que
queremos q este yo creo que es la jugada
que estamos asistiendo en este momento
en la que vamos a ver una escalada
o sea Rusia ahora trata de sostener este
control sobre estos territorios a toda
costa La movilización que estamos viendo
en Rusia la vocalización general
anunciada como parcial pero que como
vemos en general básicamente Busca
poblar el llenar aumentar el volumen de
tropas aunque sea sin apenas formación
sin apenas
en fin sin ninguna mejora en los
sistemas de adiestramiento ni en el
desempeño va a tener claramente una
mejora en el desempeño de las fuerzas
armadas rusas pero si aumenta el volumen
de fuerzas allí con vistas a sostener
esto de forma porque el crimen necesita
ganar tiempo y lograron un acuerdo
rápidamente porque está perdiendo los
ucranianos están avanzando y Rusia está
perdiendo la guerra todo esto va en esa
clave no O sea que tiene un punto de
digamos de desesperación así que de
momento la cuestión del armamento
nuclear táctico es básicamente
Buscando el efecto intimidatorio para
cambiar la dinámica diplomática
alrededor del conflicto para que
occidente la Unión Europea en Reino
Unido y Estados Unidos se abstengan de
seguir manteniendo sus suministros de
armas a los ucraneos que son los que les
permite pues tener digamos sostener esta
ofensiva con la que están derrotando y
expulsando a los rusos de su territorio
claro nicolájese también mucha
información Se está produciendo en Rusia
en las últimas horas también se conoció
por parte de Estados Unidos que hizo un
llamado a sus ciudadanos para que
abandonen lo antes posible
en Rusia porque está haciendo este
llamado Estados Unidos que se puede leer
Bueno yo creo que hay dos elementos uno
es todos aquellos ciudadanos que tengan
doble nacionalidad que Rusia no reconoce
porque Rusia tiene tratados de doble
nacionalidad o muy pocos tratados de
donde o convenios de doble nacionalidad
es decir que aquellos que tengan
nacionalidad estadounidense pero
previamente tuvieran la ciudadanía rusa
Rusia lo sigue reconociendo como
nacionales de Rusia y en consecuencia
pueden ser movilizados y digamos pues la
embajada o el consulado norteamericano
en Rusia pues tendría poco margen de
maniobra para ayudar a estos que
considera sus ciudadanos y Rusia los
considera también sus propios ciudadanos
el segundo elemento es que
en Washington y Londres a diferencia de
lo que sucede en la mayor parte de
capitales de Europa occidental Bruselas
Berlín París Madrid Roma se considera la
el escenario de una escalada seria con
Rusia que pueda conducir a Bueno pues a
un cierto nivel de enfrentamiento ya
veremos cuál se considera un escenario
posible y que está ahí no Mientras que
Europa occidental bueno Esto se sigue
contemplando todavía como una crisis que
está pasando en La periferia Europea y
no tanto como una guerra que atañe
directamente a los europeos no sé si
está la visión en la Europa central y
oriental y nórdica pero sí en la parte
de la Europa digamos occidental y
meridional
Nicolás También estamos viendo desde el
día de ayer en las acusaciones de mutuas
de lo que ocurre con el gasoducto North
Stream esta fugaza de gas en el mar
Báltico y también en estos últimos
minutos después Alemania dijo que
probablemente estos gasoductos ya
quedarían inhabilitados o por siempre
también el Cómo cambia Cómo incrementa
esto el conflicto las sanciones que
podría también manejar la Unión Europea
contra Rusia y cómo quedaría afectada la
Unión Europea también en el suministro
de gas también de cara al invierno que
es ya en dos meses
bueno en este momento hay un cruce de
acusaciones no y lo que vemos también es
desde ayer justo en el momento en que se
conoció que se había producido este
Sabotaje una campaña de operación de
información y de desinformación de rusa
en las redes sociales con vistas se
acusar a Estados Unidos no que no parece
una acusación muy verosímil pero que
está cogiendo cierta atracción en redes
sociales que como sabemos eso Pues tiene
un impacto las opiniones públicas no de
momento digamos la hipótesis más
probable sigue siendo la del Sabotaje
ruso ya veremos más adelante en que
queda porque en las investigaciones esto
es probable que se acabe Sabiendo con un
grado razonable de certeza lo sabremos
yo creo que no en demasiado tiempo
esto evidentemente Bueno pues yo creo
que es parte de esta estrategia de
escalar y elevar la tensión a la que
hago referencia no y que y con la que
Rusia Busca aumentar este nivel de
presión sobre los europeos no hay que
recordar también que esta es una
instalación que una infraestructura que
ya no se estaba utilizando que está
ahora mismo su uso en Así que en ese
sentido el impacto lo que tiene que ver
con el suministro de gas es es reducido
o menor pero sí evidentemente genera
tiene un impacto psicológico que también
contribuye a aumentar los precios a su
vez porque puede generar nerviosismo los
mercados y además es un recordatorio de
que Europa está en una situación de
mucha vulnerabilidad no también
no el Problema quizás no va a ser tanto
este otoño y este otoño invierno que
viene pero si a partir de ahí una vez
que las reservas europeas se agoten pues
no está nada claro como las va a digamos
a rellenar no los depósitos que van a
quedar vacíos previsiblemente en los
próximos meses no así que es un
recordatorio y también es una señal es
posible si ha sido Rusia no como parece
que apuntan al menos las primeras
investigaciones si ha sido Rusia
finalmente si esto Se confirma Bueno
pues es un una señal clara no de que
puede atacar infraestructuras de este
tipo que eso también sería claramente un
movimiento escalatorio no atacar una
infraestructura crítica Pues
evidentemente en el marco otan o el
marco de países no como Noruega o Reino
Unido pueden claramente interpretarlo y
concebirlo como un acto de guerra que
merece por ejemplo en el caso del marco
otan la activación del artículo 5